I moved to this parsh neighborhood in
Copenhagen and and it not it knocked on
my door and there was this famous Danish
children psychologist standing there in
the snow and he said did you do a movie
called phiston or the celebration a film
I did some years ago I said yes well
then there's another movie also I have
to do
I said well fine and good evening and
close the door and he said well read
these files please and I did seven years
later when I needed a psychiatrist for
myself so I read these cases and I was
shocked by them and thrilled and
horrified and a lot of different
emotions it came to me
and I also thought that there was a
potential drama great drama in it and I
felt it was an important story to tell
as well the children are victims again
in these kind of cases a child like her
in the movie or those in the real life
who grows up in a perfect illusion that
something happened to them being sent to
the gynecologist being interrogated
having a mother crying and father
getting into fights someone is being
sent to prison maybe someone she really
likes ends up believing that this has
happened it's getting implanted in the
memory it's what what is called added
memory and they grow up as victims and
grow up with similar problems as those
who are real victims and I thought that
was something that needed to be told it
was very important for for Thomas and
Tobias and and and also when I read it
that that we didn't make it into a
thriller for us it would be cheaper now
we wanted it to be a film about the
interaction between people and how in
this case great love can turn into
enormous fear and eventually enormous
hate and how simple and small means that
takes it was a challenge you you know
people people are used to the convention
of
being played around with and they expect
that so every time we had a camera in a
bit of a low ankle and steamy glasses on
Matt's and he did look a bit pedophile
we had to change the ankle very quickly
I've always wanted to work with summers
and then he gave me the script and I
found it beautiful and heartbreaking and
and also very very frustrating to read I
think we all have that feeling I did
that at least when I read it that I
needed something to happen what why why
is you're not doing it I needed my anger
to go somewhere I wanted to hit
something I wanted to scream out
something but but but I couldn't point
my finger at any enemy I I understood my
friend I understood the principal at the
kindergarten I understood the little kid
so that's frustration here was was a was
a good reason to shield this fellow my
thing and make this film like it was
because that's exactly how Lucas feels
and like what we experienced and when we
watch it we cannot put our anger
anywhere what do you guys learn as
filmmakers in in doing this film every
making of a film has its own mysteries
if you find the right balance between
preparing a lot of preparation a lot of
hard work and then letting go letting
letting the irrationalities take over
then you're in a good place
Matz was very thorough asked a lot of
questions we worked through the script
worked it over again changed the
character from what it was in the script
to something else and constantly refined
the material up until in front of the
camera and then he could let go then he
could cry then he could distant isn't
that and that for me was a preparation
write writing and getting it together
what writing was it was a long time I
think it was you know I was doing other
projects I'm doing theater at the same
time as it but it was like was over a
year I tried to sit in America it took
one and a half hour to find out that
would never be possible to finance a
story like that
we can still be surprised about what
what we do and what the result is even
though you plan as much as we did and
we're anticipating a certain atmosphere
or a certain scene that we'll do this
and this for the film you will still get
surprised with another scene that that's
something you did not expect and for me
that was maybe one of my maybe my
favorite scene in the film is with the
scene where the little girls being
interviewed by this psychiatrist which
is an actual transcript transcript from
an interview even in Norway with a
little girl so when I read it I was like
I don't believe that but it was actually
much worse I had to check things out so
but it's that is obviously horrifying
watching but because she was so good and
because everything was so magic about
what she did and they keep asking a
question she wants to go out and play
with her friends and she's she's feeling
embarrassed about the whole thing
but when she eventually goes knock
nodding when you ask Korea did it happen
in this room and she eventually got just
gives up and not it was a little it was
a little watch in the back room that
went ding at that moment and right there
the first time I saw it I wouldn't like
his life is over this man's life is over
because of that little not believe me
it's much much worse when you read these
cases what what people do a lot of the
times it's the parents themselves who go
back to their kids and they keep asking
the same question until the kid nuts and
until the kid starts dreaming that
answer and it becomes part of their
memory I just want to add and I'm sure I
don't have to say this but we're not
questioning the fact that there are
thousands and thousands of kids being
abused out there this is not what this
film is about this is obviously a take
on the other side of the coin we still
know that and that's a lot of work to do
out there
for the little ones but we're making a
film to clarify that you can also be a
victim as a little kid when the other
set happens